well I've got here I have got a super
egg this is from the 1970s in this
wonderful leather pouch that you do is
very very Game of Thrones and ad it pops
even though it's an egg it's an egg that
stays up absolutely beautiful
yeah and it's a mathematical object and
the history of this object is
fascinating it's a great story and it's
also leads to some really quite good fun
maths so why don't I tell you the story
it all starts with Swedish town planners
and Swedish town planners circles talk
is a square or it's actually not square
this is the problem it was a rectangle
in the middle of Stockholm and they
wanted to put a roundabout in it okay if
they were going to put a circle you know
you're wasting this space no circle if
you put an ellipse this is an ellipse
here it's too narrow the traffic is
going to get squashed couldn't an
ellipse so they were thinking about what
shapes they could use and they end up
asking this Danish guy he was actually a
poet and a mathematician like an amazing
Renaissance man called Pete Hein and
Piet Hein came up with a solution and
the solution was something called a
super ellipse I'm going to just start
with the equation for a circle x squared
plus y squared equals 1 ok this is 1
this is a circle let's play around with
this but let's enlarge the exponent so
let's it go to X say to the 4 plus y to
the 4 equals 1 what this turns into and
these are actually called lawmakers is
that it gets a little bit fatter it's a
little bit fatter okay it's like it's
becoming a square so if we did the
square this is the square it's becoming
a little bit towards it so I apologize
for my rubbish writing let's go to X to
the 8 plus y
to the eight equals one this looks
basically looks like you know a baby
Bell cheese stuck in a box if we were to
go to say X to the infinity plus wise
infinity equals one it would be the
square okay so by playing around with
the exponent it sort of pops out and get
approaches are in the limit the square
exactly you could call it a skwerkel
let's now start with an ellipse this is
a really rubbish ellipse the equation
for this is x over three squared plus y
over 2 2 squared equals one and let's do
exactly the same thing if we were to
turn this to a four it gets a bit
chunkier we were to then turn it to an
eight you'd get even it would be almost
looking like the rectangle so what Piet
Hein who had to try and find a shape for
the traffic to go round in circles talk
is that he started so just say here this
is the aerial view of circles talk and
he started with the ellipse which as I
said before Kaduna looks it's too narrow
here and he actually increased the
exponent to get what he called a super
ellipse so the super ellipse is halfway
in between the actual lips and the
rectangle and the exponent that he felt
was both most aesthetic and the most
practical was 2.5 and it is true that
this was then implemented and circles
tall which is it's got this kind of
horrible kind of obelisk
in the center at the moment it's bright
in the center of Stockholm but more than
that this shape it became an icon of
1970s design and the Azteca Stadium
where the file of the World Cup was held
you look at the roof the Azteca Stadium
that's a super ellipse and there's loads
of other Danish design that used this
shape and what Piet Hein discovered was
that if he was going to make his super
ellipse three dimensional it looked like
this and actually it was an ellipse
because obviously the ellipse would just
fall over it's got a peak that the super
lips actually stands Lama a French
mathematician also did work on this
sometimes they called lawmakers but now
because Piet Hein so famous
there were people super ellipse is this
numberphile videos made possible by the
mathematical sciences Research Institute
but we'd also like to thank a special
sponsor for this video audible.com they
are the leading provider of audiobooks
and other spoken word publications they
have loads of stuff on their website at
seemingly endless and among them is
actually the book Alex's adventures in
numberland by Alex bellos who is the
person you just watched in this video
and one of the best things about this
audiobook is not only is a brilliant
best-selling book but it's read by Alex
himself so you can hear him tell you all
about it entering the world of maths as
an adult was very different from
entering it as a child and yes there is
a whole bunch of stuff about super
ellipsis in this book and if you want to
look for some other mathematical reading
world there's loads of stuff on audible
so go to audible.com in fact if you go
to audible.com slash numberphile though
know you came from here and you can also
sign up for their 30-day trial which
lets you download a free audio book and
you could make it
Alex's adventures in numberland if you
want or one of the countless other ones
they have available thanks to audible
for their support of this video